اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط مسيره
اوكرانيه في اجواء منطقه بيلجورود غربيه
البلاد من جهه قال الرئيس الاوكراني ان
دفعته الجويه اعترضت فجر اليوم 34 طائره
مسيره من نوع شاهد من اصل 44 اطلقها الروس
باتجاه الاراضي الاوكرانيه واشار الجيش
الاوكراني الى ان دفاعاته الجويه اسقطت
سته طائرات استطلاع روسيه اضاف ان قواته
خاضت اكثر من 20 اشتباكا مع القوات
الروسيه على مختلف جبهات القتال في
الساعات القليله الماضيه وكشف الجيش
الاوكراني ان القوات الروسيه نفذت سبعة
وخمسين غاره جويه وخمسين هجوما صاروخيا
لافتا الى ان قوته نجحت في صد هجمات روسيه
في مقاطعه
واوضح الجيش الاوكراني انه يواصل الهجوم
في محور زابوروجيا الجنوبي باتجاه مدينه
ميليتوبل وقال ان القوات الروسيه نفذت 148
هجوما خلال الساعات الاخيره في زبوروجيا
اضاف ان الهجوم الروسي استهدف سبعا وعشرين
بلده قريبه من خط موجه حيث سجل سقوط 125
قذيفه في هذه البلدات